hi there thanks for tuning in my name is
Tim Bray and I work in the identity
group at Google and today with me I have
my name is Brenna and I'm an engineer
with the identities team at Google he's
being modest he's the tech lead was the
identity team I work with at Google so
there's been a lot of news just over the
last few weeks about this major horrific
password dump exposed on the open
Internet I don't want to mention the
company's name because they're good
people you know we got nothing against
them but the numbers are kind of
spine-chilling we're talking about north
of a hundred million user name password
records dumped out there into the open
space and and this might be the biggest
such leak ever so I mean really how bad
is it I think there's to some extent an
over reaction in the sense that we've
had occasional breeches like this
perhaps not exactly this magnitude but
large breaches and those repeated
occurrences so it's something that we
sort of come to expect that you're going
to be to hear about large password
database is being compromised and linked
into the Internet so why is it bad why
is it a bad thing brokers well obviously
for the company that lost the password
database it's it's an embarrassing event
and it's also an inconvenience for the
users because they're going to force the
users to sort of recover the accounts
it's really I had to change mine yeah
right and I made some users might have
difficulty doing this so they might they
will probably lose the number of
customers on that after that event and
so there's a big impact to the company
involved but for the users there's also
a big impact because many users have a
small number of passwords that they
reuse across sites and so what is going
to happen is once the developers crack
this passwords and they have the
association bit of the username to the
password they can attempt to compromise
the counts in other sites using those
credentials right but the passwords were
encrypted so shouldn't we be safe
so if it actually depends a lot on the
type of encryption that was used so for
instance when you have encryption or
hash and it doesn't involve salts then
techniques such as rainbow tables which
is it's a highly parallelizable
technique so attackers can for instance
run jobs in any cloud service and a
crack a very large percentage of the of
the database after given some amount of
time so this is really bad stuff and you
know most of many of the people who
listen to the GDL series here are app
developers themselves so so what can we
tell app developers to avoid them being
the next news story about their
passwords having been dumped right so as
an app developer eight you are worried
about the repetition of your app you're
worried about losing users once they
can't recover accounts after an event
like this and if you can't afford to
invest the security effort to protect a
password database is better to not be in
the business of having passwords to
start with and managing them so roughly
speaking are we talking give me a rough
idea of the scale at which Google does
this kind of work in particular a google
has a fairly large security team we're
talking about hundreds of people
considering not only the score of the
security team but also embedded security
people in other teams and also the I
know these are many of them well known
professionals that had a reputation
established before they join Google we
are talking there the security community
is is growing but you know it's it's a
skill that is in short supply right and
let's be honest my opinion is that in
the case of the big Internet companies
most of them are pretty good I mean
facebook to be honest it is really quite
good so if i'm going to do that get out
of the out of the password business and
rely on google or facebook or twitter or
Microsoft or whoever for that that's it
that's a pretty tough decision to take
you know I'm going to put my eggs in
their basket and
and how do I get comfortable with making
that kind of a decision I think it
starts with a realistic assessment of
the of how good a job you can doing
house right I think it's very easy to
see the risks what happens if the system
is down or what happens if the system
has been compromised itself as opposed
to understand your internal risks many
many people think that you know the the
secure the Internet companies are
divided into the ones that know they had
that have been hacked and the ones that
don't and so do you really have a good
grasp on what has happened in terms of
security of environment can you assess
the risk correctly can you assess the
cost and the and how often your system
will not be the operational also so you
have to make a cost-benefit analysis
with other risks involved and look at
the operational records of these
companies and and and you know Assessor
there's any other technology that or
outsource services would might use right
let me expand at one point that the
brand I made there you know he's talked
about the companies that know they've
been hacked and the ones that don't and
two things from that you know even the
best companies get hacked sometimes you
know I said here at Google and I see
emails go buy some time saying Oh
obscure cross-site scripting
vulnerability discovered in line 8035 of
you know of this file here and I guess
the difference is that a place like like
Google we have people whose job it is to
notice that and and to fix it when it
happens and and the thing that really
troubles me is not so much the the
individual site getting hacked is when a
popular web framework like nodejs or
rails gets half and has a zero-day
vulnerability you're looking at you know
a hundred thousand sites all of a sudden
being being being wide open to attack so
let me follow up let me just emphasize a
point you just made or get you to do
that you said well you don't have to do
a cost-benefit analysis it sounds like
you the same kind of thing you do when
you outsource your your financials or
your HR is that really a good way to
think about it I'm sure if you all saw
some financials that we're taking a set
of risks
that would be different if you kept them
in house so yes I would say similar in
addition to the cost-benefit ratio you
also need to look at the realistic like
measures of the benefit because you may
have additional benefits like you may
reduce friction on account sign up and
you might reduce friction on login
because if the users come to your site
and the already logged into I dental
provider such as Google Facebook a
common and then to provider and
Microsoft they will probably have an
easier time login to your site and so
you might see increased measures of user
engagement of account creation and you
know user acquisition so in addition to
the you know standard cost-benefit ratio
of outsourcing some technology there's
potentially a large untapped benefit
that and that you are you know leaving a
you know a missing out on fair enough
that's a good point perhaps the most
crucial point in the relationship
between your app and in a user is that
moment when they first sign up right and
anything you can do to reduce the
friction of getting somebody signed up
and on board is a major business plus
and if you can do that and reduce risk
at the same time now if you really must
be in the fast food business if for some
reason regulatory reasons or whatever
you must be in the password business
there's a lot of good online resources
about how to hash and how to crypt and
how to salt and so on if you were going
to do this what would be your top couple
of recommendations I guess the first one
we don't but right I think you know the
actual security of implementing the
password system is in some sense the
easiest one to get it right because
there are good references online the
hardest thing to do is the overall
integrity of your password operations
right you are going to have to expose
the password verification system
eventually to a login box somewhere and
then you have to worry about you know
your whole stack leading up to the to
the point where you contact your
password database to have security depth
you can have multiple roadblocks to a
developer actually gaining
administrative control over your
password system and extracting the
password database I think that's the
hard part quite quite frankly fair
enough but our recommendation would be
don't do it get out of the password
business so thank you for tuning in
Brenda and I are both pretty easy to
find out and find online if you are
interested in these issues get in touch
with us directly and once again thank
you for tuning in thank you